Как правильно отказывать и как правильно
говорить Нет почему у вас не всегда это
получается а потом вы жалеете у каждого
наверное в жизни была такая ситуация
когда вас куда-то пригласили или вам
что-то предложили или вам нужно куда-то
идти и вы не можете отказать или вы
боитесь что если вы откажете то на вас
обидится Давайте поговорим о том как
правильно людям отказывать и при этом
чтобы они не обижались и Как выходить из
таких затруднительных ситуаций зачастую
Почему вы не можете отказывать и не
можете говорить Нет происходит по трём
основным причинам первая причина - это
то что у вас нету целей Потому что когда
у вас есть чёткая цель вы чётко
понимаете кому отказывать как отказывать
когда отказывать и вы не особо
заботитесь по поводу того как другая
сторона воспримет ваш отказ например А
вас пригласили на ужин А вы готовитесь
там к Айрон мну и у вас ежедневный
тренировки и вам условно нельзя ужинать
Боитесь сорваться уже осталось там месяц
до заплыва и до соревнования
соответственно вам легко отказать вам
легче отказать потому что у вас есть
конкретная цель и у вас есть
причина отказать потому что в любом
отказе существуют две стороны Та сторона
которой вы отказываете и вторая сторона
- это вы сами Если у вас нету причины
отказать другой ране то вы не можете
отказать потому что вы сами про себя
начнёте плохо думать а когда у вас есть
причина которую вы сами себя обосновали
что вы готовитесь к Айрон мену и Вам
нельзя срываться и остался месяц до
соревнования вы себе чётко это
обосновали аргументировать вам легче
объяснить И отказать это другому
человеку Вторая причина
а при которой вам тяжело отказывать и
как с этим бороться это у вас должно
быть что-то с чем вам сравнивать можно
сравнивать то есть я называю ещё
альтернативное использование либо
альтернативный способ действий
предположим если у вас вас пригласили на
ужин Ну вы хотите провести ужин с семьёй
либо вас друзья зовут в баню У вас есть
два варианта действий и вам легче
отказать Когда у вас есть два варианта
действий и вы взвешивай что для вас
ценнее не обязательно ужин с семьёй
убеждает Многие думают там ужин с семьёй
конечно ценнее не всегда Так например
если вы молодая семья и для вас очень
важно сделать бизнес либо вырасти по
служебной карьере то Вы спокойно можете
супруге объяснить что мне нужно пойти с
друзьями или с коллегами в баню для того
чтобы укрепить свои отношения и наладить
новые связи которые помогут мне
заработать больше денег и соответственно
работает на нашу семью ваша супруга ни в
коем случае не обидится потому что она
знает что вы это делаете для неё в том
числе поэтому Когда у вас есть
альтернативный вариант действий вам
легче отказать потому что у вас есть
сравнение во-первых У вас есть причина
друзьям Вы можете сказать что нет не
могу мы с семьёй сегодня запланировали
ужин Если вы выбираете ужин с семьёй
либо супруги вы всегда можете сказать
почему надо идти потому что там будут
такие-то люди знакомство с которыми
близкие отношения которыми для вас очень
важно важно для вашей карьеры для вашего
бизнеса То есть во-первых у вас есть
причина а а во-вторых у вас есть
альтернативный способ действия и вы
можете их сравнивать и понимать чему
отказать А чему сказать да Третий фактор
- это когда у вас есть просто
уважительная причина например А у вас
заболел кто-то из родственников нужно
срочно висить в больнице На каком бы
мероприятии вы не сидели вы всегда
можете подойти к организатору
обратиться и сказать что вот у меня
такая-то ситуация Мне надо срочно идти и
вас поймут Или вы можете также уйти с
работы уйти с Любой вечеринки с любого
мероприятия Если у вас есть на то
уважительная причина Вот это три случая
Когда вы должны понять когда вы можете
легко отказать людям и сказать Нет
Наверняка у вас тоже было очень много
случаев в жизни когда вам приходилось
придумывать уважительную причину и я
понимаю что когда время придумывать
уважительную причину Это не вопрос того
чтобы обмануть кого-то Вы наверняка это
делали для того чтобы не обидеть другого
чтобы у вас была уважительная причина
это и чтобы сохранить отношения
Наверняка у вас у всех скорее всего
бывали такие ситуации или случаи когда
вам надо вот прямо по зарез надо
отказать действительно у вас
уважительная причина и вы не
задумывались о последствиях не
задумывались об отношениях спокойно
говорили спокойно говорили нет спокойно
отказывались и уходили и это никак не
влияло на ваши отношения второй вариант
а Опишите случаи когда у вас не было
уважительной причины но Вы придумывали
для того чтобы уйти с какого-нибудь
мероприятия которое вам не нравится
которое вам не по душе тоже интересно А
мне почитать И вообще чтобы другие люди
тоже посмотрели Поделитесь обязательно
своим мнением и не забывайте Кстати
подписываться на канал ставить лайки
колокольчики и так далее А мы пойдём
дальше почему важны эти Т вещи о которых
мы говорили Давайте вкратце я повторюсь
первое наличие цели второе - это
альтернативный альтернативный способ
поведения или действий и третья
уважительная причина Я заметил такую
вещь что люди не могут отказать в
основном из-за того что у них нету
Аргументов нету причины причём причина
она важна даже не столько Тем людям
которым отказываешь А самому самому себе
Вот кстати был интересный ещё такой
феномен Нако это глубоко в нас сидит
всех проводили
эксперимент по-моему в гарварде или
где-то там люди стояли в очереди и
человек подходил и говорил другим людям
можно Я пройду без очереди так вот в 9
там 6% случаев его не пускали без
очереди все возмущались И никто его не
пропускал А когда человек этот же
человек в другой очереди приходил и
говорил можно Я пройду без очереди
потому что мне надо его пропускали почти
68%
странно он не привёл какого-то
конкретного аргумента но он сказал
Пропустите меня пожалуйста без очереди
потому что мне надо само наличие причины
потому что мне надо уже запускает у нас
подсознательный Триггер в голове и мы
подсознательно или можно сказать
бессознательно позволяем другому
человеку идти без очереди это вы
наверное тоже видели во многих очередях
когда Какие наглые типы есть есть даже
определённая категория людей которые
пользуются и заходит в какую-то очередь
и говорит мне надо мне срочно надо как
будто другим людям стоящим в очереди
времени девать некуда и им срочно не
надо а вот он приходит говорит там лезет
в очереди все когда начинают возмущаться
он говорит мне срочно надо его
пропускают и этот как раз тот
подсознательный Триггер механизм при
котором
человек принимает отказ потому что в нас
это глубоко сидит наличие причины есть
категория людей которым не сложно
отказать и им нужна просто причина для
этого вот три причины я сказал а есть
категория людей которые застенчивые
которые не могут отказать И вот я из
своего опыта скажу что мы проводили
Однажды инвест буткемп в Стамбуле и ко
мне обратился один Бизнесмен и говорит
Марч У меня проблемы Я не могу отказать
друзьям родственникам знакомым они у
меня просят деньги Я не не могу отказать
в результате много людей мне в
результате много В какие проекты Я залез
всё это потери денег не приносит мне
денег и я не могу отказать А я говорю а
хорошо ладно там и вот мы ведём буткемп
и на второй день он подходит ко мне и
говорит марн калич Я слышал что вы
продаёте какую-то долю акции в какой-то
компании я говорю да продаю он говорит А
можно я поучаствую Я хочу
проинвестировать я говорю Ну да в
принципе тебе могу дать такую
возможность он обрадовался начал мне
руку пожимать говорит Спасибо марн колич
там что дали такую возможность и так
далее я рад быть с вами партнёром я
говорю подожди Подожди я тебе ещё не дал
окончательное добро я тебе дам добро
когда ты пройдёшь bootcamp
инвестиционный bootcamp там как раз про
то как надо инвестировать как надо
инвестиционный портфель делать и так
далее так вот на третий день он подходит
ко мне и говорит Марго колич Я хотел бы
с вами поговорить Я говорю да а он
говорит Можно я откажусь откажусь от
возможности Я говорю Да А в чём причина
он говорит начал писать инвестиционную
декларацию Как вы меня Учите и понял что
у меня и так весь бизнес в Казахстане А
теперь А я хочу определённую
Независимость и иметь инвестиции за
рубежом и получается Если я зайду в этот
проект то у меня опять инвестиции будет
в Казахстане Поэтому мне надо
инвестировать за рубежом и я ему говорю
засмеялся и говорю Смотри ты тот человек
который мне до этого буквально полтора
дня назад говорил о том что ты не можешь
отказать друзьям родственникам знакомым
и так далее а особенно известным людям
которых Ты уважаешь и вот прямо сейчас
ты это сделал Ты отказал мне я известный
человек Ты меня уважаешь А до этого ты
восторженно благодарил меня за такую
возможность А теперь спокойно отказал и
у тебя нету ни зазрение какого-то
совесть не то что совесть ты даже не
чувствуешь себя обязанным чуть-чуть не
чувствуешь вот этой робости боязни
спокойно отказал говорю почему потому
что у тебя а появилась цель б у тебя
есть причина отказать и ты Спокойно это
делаешь поэтому те люди которые считают
себя робким и которые считают что они не
могут никому отказать на самом деле а
вся основная причина только в том что
поработайте значит у вас нету целий
Значит вам не с чем сравнивать И третье
у вас нету действительно важное причины
отказать если вот этих трёх вещей нету
они как бы у нас как предохранители то
наш мозг настроен на автоматическое
говорить Да автоматически мы говорим Да
у нас не настроено Так что автоматически
отказывать у нас автоматически настроено
говорить Да поэтому мы отказать не можем
если нету на то причин А я работаю
чуть-чуть по другому принципу Я исхожу
из Так что вообще в каких случаях
говорить да В каких случаях говорить Нет
неважно это покупка неважно это пойти на
какое-то
мероприятие там неважно Это какое-то
предложение я схожу так если у меня нету
ощущения что точно да то скорее всего
Нет смотрите интересный психологический
момент когда я делаю какую-то покупку
Если у меня нету железобетонной
уверенности то значит нет Вот ещё ещё
очень важно поймать такую вещь и
напишите в комментариях мне интересно
тоже почитать это когда ты начинаешь
искать аргумент и почему эта покупка
Классная то скорее всего у Вас нету
реальной причины её покупать то есть
если вы пишете я покупаю такую машину
потому что она такая потому что такая
потому что такая то есть вы как бы сами
себе доказываете значит у вас реально
нету уважительной причины её покупать
Потому что когда у вас есть причина вы
себе не доказываете вы просто покупайте
может быть причины Просто ощущение вот
очень хочу вот именно такую просто
нравится тоже аргумент тоже аргумент это
должна быть цель
А как я говорил при покупке любых вещей
нужно понимать Какую функцию эта вещь
будет вам закрывать и соответствует ли
это вашей цели кстати об этом Об о том
как
психология бедная психология и богатая
психология влияет на покупки вещей я
рассказал в предыдущем видео обязательно
посмотрите там тоже много интересных
вещей я говорил важно здесь понимать
такую вещь что возможность или
способность умения говорить нет И
отказывать - Это не вопрос манипуляции
или психологических трюков я
рассматриваю более фундаментальные вещи
если вы фундаментально а правильно к
этому вопросу подходите то вам легко
будет отказать я мало верю во всякие
психологические трюки и инструменты Если
у вас нету базы фундамента Если вы
хотите более подробно знать об этих и
других интересных вещах связанных с
психологией эффективностью бизнесом
инвестициями и так далее переходите в
мой Telegram канал ссылку я оставляю
внизу а там мы можем говорить более
подробно и самый главный
способ научиться говорить Нет я ей
правильно отказывать заключается в том
что когда вы транслируется своему
окружению и всем людям свои цели то вы
становитесь предсказуемым и фокус здесь
заключается в том что даже когда вы
отказали Без объяснения причин люди сами
придумывают за вас причины почему вы
отказались Это самый лучший способ
отказывать например вы готовитесь к он
заплыв какому-то Да тренируетесь вы в
строгом режиме и вам позвонили друзья
говорит Пойдём в баню дальше поужинаем
ты говоришь извинить ребята Нет не могу
и всё положили трубку вы не дали никаких
объяснений Так вы думаете они обидятся
Нет они зная ваши цели они скажут но
марн отказал потому что у него Он
готовится КНУ его понять можно Он
готовится к Оушен мену у него там
строгий режим подготовка режим питания и
так далее тренировки поэтому он нам
отказал то есть люди не обидятся и
придумают сами придумают за вас причины
вашего отказа Если вы транслируется свои
цели окружающему миру своим друзьям
знакомым родственникам и так далее
поэтому Будьте
предсказуемыми
транслируется Много и часто отказывать
И самое главное что вы легко сможете
отказывать и не обижать людей люди сами
вас оправдают и объяснят причины по
которым вы это сделали я уверен это
видео будет полезно каждому из вас
Подписывайтесь ставьте лайки следите за
следующими выпусками Теперь мы выпуски
делаем каждую неделю